Destin: "You wanna do it,  yeah, do it"
"Very good"
"Hey it's me Destin, welcome back to
Smarter Every Month... day! Smarter Every Day"
"If you've never had four children you know
that four children are a handful."
"Today on smarter every day my wife and I decide,
well, here let me just show you what the deal is."
"Question. Question time. What is the most
important relationship in our family?
Kids:  "Mom and Dad"
Destin: "Why?"
Kids: "cause if y'all break up, we won't be a family anymore"
Destin: "Is that going to happen?"
Kids: "Nope"
Destin: "Why?"
Kids: " 'cause of strong relationships"
Destin: "Why are you sayin that? Did I tell you to say that?"
Kids: "No"
Destin: "Okay that's just the way it is?"
Kids: "Yep"
(Destin's whoosing noise and excited child's noise)
Destin: "Okay, so, today on Smarter Every Day we're
going to go to Iceland because my wife
and I want to go on aniver.."
(to child) "You wanna jump?"
"We want to go on an anniversary adventure,
somewhere we haven't been before and we
don't know the culture.
So after talking with John Green who said Iceland is a
really great place to go, we decided to go.
So let's go get Smarter Every Day in Silfra, Iceland where
you can scuba dive between the continents."
(Narrating) Kids make it really hard to travel but
every once in a while we get to go on a
trip that's just us. It's like going on
an adventure with your best friend.
Anyway, we love iceland as a choice
because we didn't know the language,
we didn't know the culture - we had to figure
all that stuff out together.
One thing I really like every time I go
to a new country is to experience the
currency for the first time because that
tells you a little bit about the people.
Destin: "Lady with funny hat is 40 dollars"
Destin: "Dude with big nose"
Tara: "80" dollars
Destin: (shocked) "This is 80 dollars? This is not 80 dollars"
(Narrating) We usually plan everything out but in this case we
only booked one thing which is diving at Silfra.
Everything else we play by ear
which is pretty easy because Iceland is
crazy beautiful.
We saw geysers, we rode four wheelers, we
picked up hitchhikers, we visited several
waterfalls - which by the way I recorded
for the new channel called The Sound
Traveler. If you're interested go check
it out I think you'll really enjoy it.
Anyway it was great, and for me the common
theme was connecting with my wife and
strengthening the foundation for our
family; and it's pretty easy to tell by
looking at her eyes here that that
seemed to work.
Right so Iceland is cold,
like really really cold and we're about
to go diving here. This spot for example
is just a few dozen miles from where our dive
site is and those are icebergs.
I mean they're beautiful but like,
icebergs touching this water and knowing
I'm going to get into it made me
appreciate seals on a completely different level.
Tara: "They can shut off blood flow to
certain areas in order to preserve... vital areas.
does that makes sense?"
Destin: "Yeah"
Destin: "Do you remember plate tectonics from like
elementary school? We're at a place called
Silfra and this is where the North
American plate and the Eurasian plate
which is on the other side of this
valley here this is where they meet.
And so we're about to go dive... where?
Point out to me."
Tara: "Ooh. Out there, second patch of cars."
(Narrating) The North American plate and the Eurasian Plate
are pulling apart and these divergent
plates or what's called the mid-Atlantic ridge.
Long story short this is why we
have Iceland and it's why you have both
glaciers *and* volcanoes in the exact same
area creating some incredible rock formations.
Silfra is right in the middle of this.
This is our divemaster Tebow.
He explained that because Silfra is fed by
glacier water that's been filtered
through volcanic rock for over 30 years
before it reaches the site, it's one of
the highest visibility dives in the world.
Just as a point of reference this
is the visibility my friend and I
experienced during a shipwreck dive in
the Gulf of Mexico earlier this year.
It's really neat but you can only see a
few meters in front of your face.
Tebow said we're going to experience
over a hundred metres of visibility at
Silfra which is crazy. By the way, if
Jared and I were still cold in wet suits
80-foot below the Gulf of Mexico in summer,
how on earth are Tara and I going to
survive 80-foot below the icy waters of Silfra?
The answer is a drysuit. Water has a
thermal conductivity of 0.58 watts
per meter kelvin, while air is only 0.024.
That means if you're in direct contact
with the water you lose heat out of
your body over 20 times faster than if
you can put a small air gap between you and the water.
Because of the simple heat transfer equation,
this little air gap and some fuzzy pajamas are all you
need to protect yourself from rapid heat loss and hypothermia.
Destin: "Alright so this is the first time I've
ever had to stay dry before I went scuba
diving because we're getting in a dry suit.
And we just met Scott today, hey Scott!"
Scott: "Hey, how's it going?"
(laughter)
(narrating) It's important not to compromise the air
gap, so you have a really tight seal around
your wrist and neck so you don't spring
a leak. The gloves and hood you put on however
intentionally fill with water and your
own body heat heats that water up which
eventually becomes somewhat tolerable.
This dive is commonly called 'The Dive
Between the Continents'.
Check out how beautiful this is.
(narrating) It was super fun to learn about dry suit
diving together and it was even more
special to do it in an incredibly awesome
place like Silfra. Just like our
marriage, it's two totally different
forces that come together in this one
spot and make something beautiful.
A lot of people don't know this but Tara
has more science degrees than I do.
She's a hundred percent on board with
everything I do to try to get smarter,
and that's huge!
I think it's clear that this channel
wouldn't be possible without her support.
So happy anniversary baby.
I really miss doing stuff like this with you
aaaand back to the kids... and real-life.
"Okay, I hope you enjoyed this episode of
Smarter Every Day.
Family's important which is why today's
sponsor is Kiwi Crate. You know how this
stuff works. A company approaches a
YouTube channel and asks to advertise.
Well this is backwards, I like this
company so much because we got them for
Christmas one year, and we love them so I
asked them if they would let me
advertise for them on Smarter Every Day,
and they said yes so today what do we have,
what are those?"
Kids: "Kiwi Crate!"
Destin: "Why are you excited about the Kiwi Crate?"
Kids: "Because they're so fun"
Destin: "Koala Crate, who's that?
"Who's the Koala crate?
Why'd you go for the blue one?"
because its mine
Destin: "A doodle crate.
Ok so anyway, kiwi crate is a really,
really cool service because it gets kids
involved - they have to do things with
their hands so they have to think and
then they have to do, which I'm all for
on Smarter Every Day. I recommend the tinker
crate it's my favorite however, my
daughter said she likes the doodle crate.
You sure you don't like the tinker crate? "
Child: "I like the doodle crate"
Destin: "She likes the doodle crate.  so if you'd like
to support Smarter Every Day
please consider going to
kiwicrate.com/smarter
and you can get a free trial.
It's really cool and really worth it.
Makes really good presents.
That's it!  I'm Destin you're getting Smarter Every Day
have a good one.  Anything you want to say?"
Kids: "They're awesome"
Destin: "Are they really? You're not just saying this?"
Child: "It gives you more family time"
Destin: "So, all your skin, you pull it up above this seal
right here and ends up making an
incredible double chin like this."
Tara: "the North American plate"
Destin: "And what is this over here?"
Tara: "The Euro-Asian plate"
Destin: "Eurasian. we've said that
(laughter) can't say it.
It's Eurasian, say Eurasian."
Tara: "Eurasian"
Destin: "Eurasian Plate"
"Tebow taught me how to unzip yourself"
"Haha"
Someone in background: "If you can do that, I'll be impressed"
(sound of zipper being undone)
(small crowd cheers)
Destin: "You do know what they call a male Puffin, right?"
Tara: "No. A male Puffin"
Destin: "Puff Daddy"
Tara: "Happy anniversary"
Destin: "Happy anniversary"